well I see you've become a loyal Scott
so tell me what made you do that well
we've been member the LMA society we've
given to the University for a long time
my daughter is a senior here in cami and
materials engineering my son just got
accepted in H&S s economics my wife's
our graduate here out of what was supa
which is Heinz now so we've had a long
commitment to the University you guys
truly are applied to the bone that's
fantastic so when you were a young guy
what made you want to come to this
campus now the main reason was the job
market or the opportunities that
presented better the same today so tell
me also like how do you use your
Carnegie Mellon experience in the work
field and how does it give you an edge
over your competitors I'm vice president
engineering for a small company in
northern Pennsylvania Keystone powdered
metal and it was very helpful in getting
the job and looking at things through
the old ase program on analyzing since
the synthesizing and evaluating your
options so why do you think everybody
else should become oil Scott's well I
think they should enjoy the experience
they had here and it's probably
hopefully it's been a part of their
success so we have the plaid to the bone
family here to Carnegie Mellon how did
you meet here no we did not meet here
and you just you just loved each other
because you knew you had the same
mindset right well that he actually
talked me into getting my graduate
degree here convinced me to come to
school here because of what he believed
in the school so much so that was a
positive aspect of it and did you come
to agree with him yes I did that's a
good thing and you had some children
here as well yes our daughter is going
to be graduating in may from CIT and our
son was just recently accepted well
congratulations that's just a fantastic
legacy that's really really wonderful so
tell me um how do you think that the
Carnegie Mellon education has impacted
your work life and also your lifestyle
is a family it's given us I think
something extra in our lives it's you
you are encouraged to succeed and to do
your best here and and I think that has
followed us in into our lives and our
children were very proud to be
part of this went growing up and now
attending here as well